the learning from simply learn has been
really amazing and extremely helpful
whoever is watching this video I
recommend you go out to simply learns
website and check out their courses they
have brilliant instructors who are
industry wide solution architects and
directors working at the biggest firm
right now hi my name is Aditya and I'm
working as a consultant in eros in the
field of AI machine learning and RP I
did my engineering from Rajah Sulayman
Institute of Technology
I majored in electronics and
communication engineering I passed out
in 2013 and on campus I got placed into
a company core nucleus software so I
started working in the oppor engineering
team the team was involved into
application development using Oracle
forms equal and Database languages I
wanted to explore better technologies
which were there in the market at that
time I got to know that machine learning
and Big Data they revolve around sequel
so if you are a sequel person you are
very much comfortable with learning new
machine learning techniques and database
technologies like Big Data I do so
that's when I started looking out for
the training institutes and then my
relative Leppard me once I decided to go
for simply learn I had one course in my
mind which was Big Data only but when I
approached simply learned they offered
me a bundle of courses in one master
program which included not only big data
but also machine learning and Python
basics are basics data science with
Python and some Java fundamentals as
well so that was really good to have
what I liked most about the training was
the context of the training as well as
the instructor to student engagement
after the training I caught an
opportunity to learn more about these
technologies
and once I was done learning I attended
a lot of interviews so they were in some
vacancies and the intervals were real
life big data architects and data
science experts and they were really
happy to see the knowledge which I have
so simply learn definitely set up a base
for me on that and once I started giving
interviews eventually I landed up in a
MNC in Chennai where I'm working as a
data science expert and a consultant
simply loans big data master program
helped me to get a new job with a very
good salary hike a very big thanks to
simply learn for making me who I am I
feel really fortunate to be associated
with these technologies now I can lead
different teams and drive different
business transformation programs using
my skill set I really wanted to upskill
because in the market and in the IT
industry upscaling is really important